avec moi en plateau notre chroniqueuse
internationale Armelle charrier est avec
moi bonjour Armel bonjour on va on va
faire un petit point juste sur
l'ouverture donc de cette conférence en
surprise hein il y avait le président
Macron et le président ont insisté
là-dessus en début de l'ouverture de
cette conférence le point névralgique le
point stratégique pour le moment c'est
l'aide énergétique d'une certaine
manière à l'Ukraine pour l'aider donc
Armelle a passé l'hiver oui et surtout
en plus j'allais dire l'intérêt de cette
conférence de Paris qui est en fait
c'est un peu pour aider les civils on a
généralement une conférence qui se tient
sur la base de mindstein en Allemagne à
l'initiative des Américains pour livrer
des armes à l'Ukraine et là l'idée du
président Macron quand il était revenu
d'un voyage qu'il avait fait à Kiev où
il avait parlé au président zélinski
c'était comment est-ce qu'on aide la
population concrètement et là-dessus
c'est rajouter une vraie stratégie
j'allais dire russe qui est une
stratégie de destruction d'une partie de
l'Ukraine en touchant tout ce qui est
l'électricité tout ce qui est l'eau et
quand vous touchez l'électricité vous
touchez aussi forcément Internet vous
touchez des moyens évidemment de se
chauffer vous toucher des moyens
d'approvisionnement d'eau donc c'est
vraiment une inaptitude de vie quand on
est en zone urbaine très importante et
c'est pour ça que le président Macron
insiste sur cette capacité à un moment
donné à fournir d'une part par exemple
des générateurs donc la France on a déjà
livré 100 elle va en rajouter 63 des
groupes électrogènes qui partent
directement parce que dans ce genre de
situation il n'y a plus que ça et puis
ensuite d'avoir tout un plan avec
plusieurs dizaines de millions pour
aider clairement comment est-ce qu'on va
rétablir ces infrastructures soit
comment est-ce qu'on les répare mais ce
qu'il faut bien avoir en tête c'est qu'à
partir du moment donné où les Russes
bombardent tous les jours les
réparations que vous faites elles sont
caduques le lendemain ou alors du coup
les lignes ça faiblissent donc c'est
pour cela qu'il y a vraiment un vrai
chiffrage
juste à titre d'information le chiffrage
global qui était pour l'Ukraine ces 350
milliards de dollars 350 milliards de
dollars alors évidemment on chiffre nous
à quelques centaines de millions d'euros
aujourd'hui pour les civils mais ça
montre bien que on se retrouve avec
j'allais dire un impact russe à deux
niveaux détruire le crâne aujourd'hui
idrick ces infrastructures mais détruire
quelque part impacter l'économie
européenne parce que forcément ce sont
les pays européens derrière qui vont se
soucier de reconstruire ce pays
on l'a vu on l'a entendu lors de cette
ouverture cette conférence il le dit il
nous faut des générateurs vous l'avez
dit il nous faut également du gaz pour
pouvoir nous chauffer et même des des du
matériel qui paraît peut-être plus
insignifiants des LED il a parlé de
l'ampleur donc l'Ukraine a besoin de
tout ça pour pour passer l'hiver Armel
oui on est dans un pays où il fait très
froid donc les effets sont tout à fait
immédiat ou derrière vous avez une
guerre mener qu'il y avait un chiffre
qu'on reprend pas souvent parce que les
Ukrainiens n'ont jamais donné ni leur
nombre de morts ni leur nombre de
blessés les Américains le Pentagone l'a
donné je le reprends parce qu'il est
assez neutre il y a quand même parler de
100 000 morts ou blessés de plus haut
niveau c'est-à-dire ceux qui ne peuvent
pas retourner au combat pourquoi est-ce
que je le rappelle parce que du coup il
y a forcément des besoins de santé qui
sont très grands et lorsque le président
zellinski parle de l'amplepuis lorsqu'il
explique qu'il faut de l'aide immédiate
etc c'est que il n'y a pas que les
civils qui sont douchées dans une vie
quotidienne il y a aussi des hôpitaux de
campagne il y a aussi toute une
structure effectivement d'un pays qui
fait la guerre et qu'il l'a fait
effectivement derrière les les
Ukrainiens insistent effectivement sur
cette besoins en parlant évidemment du
risque derrière d'une vague de migration
de gens qui quitteraient l'Ukraine et
qui viendrait se réfugier en Europe un
dernier mois avec vous Armel on en
reviendra plus en détail dans nos
prochaines éditions mais sur le long
terme cette fois c'est aussi l'objectif
de cette conférence de soutien à
l'Ukraine c'est reconstruire l'Ukraine à
à plus long terme mais là aussi c'est un
enjeu majeur on l'imagine c'est un enjeu
majeur parce que c'est un pays qui est
en partie désossés aujourd'hui avec une
ligne de fracture qui est celle du
Dombas ou aujourd'hui où vous avez les
combats qui se mettent en place et où il
y a eu quand même un référendum russe
qui a dit que il a du coup la main sur
ces lignes là ça c'est pas discuter pour
l'instant ce sera la voie diplomatique
le jour où on s'assera autour d'une
table là on l'a entendu le président
Macron a dit vous nous direz vous le dit
merci quand est-ce que vous jugez bon à
un moment donné de parler mais on sait
que derrière la diplomatie
internationale et c'est quand même de
faire cesser cette guerre mais derrière
vous avez évidemment toutes les
structures routières parce que les
routes ont été endommagées même si les
ponts n'ont pas tous été cassés par les
Russes vous avez les structures
ferroviaires vous avez évidemment
l'énergie dont on parle énormément avec
les qu'avec tout cela qui va derrière et
puis vous avez aussi un pays qui a été
totalement mitraillé donc on imagine que
l'état de l'agriculture va être aussi
compliqué lorsque vous avez
effectivement des endroits qui ont été
bombardés sans cesse vous avez toute une
économie à remettre en place
l'agriculture étant fondamentale pour
les ukrainiens et le chemin s'allonce
long on Lara comprit merci beaucoup
Armel charrier pour cette an